les compétitions de jeux vidéo sont
reconnus officiellement par l'état
français depuis 2016 et on partait de
loin
retour en 1982 voici un sujet sur le
vice-champion du monde de pacman en
français s'il vous plaît
bon vous êtes jeunes vous êtes bien
portants vous avez l'air sensés
relativement intelligents et vous jouez
à des jeux que d'aucuns qualifieront de
stupide pourquoi jeu stupide abrutissant
à doha patyka sociale en 1999 le
discours n'a pas vraiment changé
exemple avec le portrait du double
champion de france et d'europe de gran
turismo et tekken 3 un drôle de monde
celui des jeux vidéo pire landouzy s'est
fait piéger dès l'âge de 7 ans donc ce
jeune homme s'est fait piéger alors que
les compétitions de jeux vidéo prennent
de plus en plus d'importance
les reportages consacrés à ce que l'on
appelle maintenant l'ispor ont toujours
incertain a priori les joueurs sont des
no life
les organisateurs de tournois tente
alors de briser ces préjugés s'est dit
au contraire qui qui sera content des
tas de trucs qui sont pas du tout fermé
qui assassine personnes dans la rue
qu'on pourra des envies meurtrière au
contraire c'est le même c'est même
principe que toutes les activités
sportif sportive
qui défoule les années passent et les
sports prend de l'ampleur avec de plus
en plus de compétitions internationales
tout ça sans publicité dans les médias
traditionnels des stars émergent et avec
leurs fans en 2007 quand le journaliste
doute de la sportivité de la discipline
réponse de l'un d'entre eux bien sûr
ceux des sportifs pour vous quelqu'un
qui passe de 5 à 10 heures par jour sur
une sur un pc comme ça qu'ils
s'entraînent qu'il faut d'extraction
énormément de choses qu'on sait que
c'est pas sportif il faudrait attendre
2016 et la loi pour une république
numérique pour que l'histoire soit
officiellement reconnu ces compétitions
légaliser et le statut des joueurs
reconnus comme professionnels
la croissance du secteur est
exponentielle un marché qui intéresse
les sponsors les marques de jeux vidéo
mais aussi certains clubs de foot qui se
mettent à recruter et gamer l'ol n'est
pas le premier club à investir ce
nouveau terrain de jeu le psg et nantes
l'ont précédé
aujourd'hui en france plus de 5 millions
d'internautes regardent du esport et
selon une note de la banque
d'investissement américaine goldman
sachs l'ispor atteindra les 300 millions
de téléspectateurs au niveau mondial en
une audience comparable à celle de la
ligue professionnelle de football
américain
[Musique]